13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
hey guys welcome back to another workout
I am so excited today because look who I
have here my partner Terrence - Terrence
is a bodybuilder and he is going to be
joining us in completing today's 30
minutes trying to work out which you can
do at home so this workout is really
good to increase your strength as well
as to sculpt your muscles because we
want to keep your heart rate up in order
to burn fat alright so there will be a
total of three circuits the first is
going to be a lower body circuit moving
on to your upper body and break this end
with a core circuit really simple all
right just follow along each workout
will be for 40 seconds long with 20
seconds in between
[Music]
I'll be ready awesome okay so let's get
straight into the workout and let's
start by just using your body weight
okay so the first workout will be a
squat to lunch
are we ready all right all right let's
go okay so stand sugar with a part and
let's squat and left leg back into a
lunge okay so alternating between legs
now right leg back into a lunge very
good
so always making sure that your toes are
pointed forward and just relax your
upper body good so no weight yet
very good so squat push your butt back
into a lunge
okay making sure you're taking a white
step back and push through your front
use nice how we doing how are you doing
Terrence good awesome last few more
squat and rest it up
okay now let's grab a medium pair of
dumbbells okay so what I have here is
four kilos so the next workout is going
to be weighted sumo squat so place both
dumbbells in front of you together step
wide with your toes pointed out okay
this is good to work on your outer
glutes and inner thighs squat down push
your butt back squeeze your butt as you
come up down and up okay so you really
want to make sure that both toes are
pointing out and you're squeezing your
glutes on the way up and you should feel
your inner thighs good squeeze back down
keep the dumbbells in front of you down
up squeeze remember to breathe out as
you come up good down squeeze few more
come on give me two more okay down push
your butt back last one more down and
squeeze huh
very good okay now still holding on to
the dumbbells okay next is going to be a
narrow to wide squat alright so place
the dumbbells on your shoulders okay
so we want to start with narrow squat so
place both leg
together all right with a toast pointer
poet ready let's go double and let's
step out and double gear that's it
step in stay low double step out double
okay so you have an option you can step
back up or maintain a low position and
pulse good in double step up and good
small pulses step in and out you should
really feel your thighs burning your
glutes burning everything if I'm
fighting right now last few more okay
ready let's go online there it's good
and let's go wide and that's it good now
let's lie down on the floor all right
let's work on your glutes still holding
onto your dumbbells place a fuse on the
floor place your dumbbells just on top
of your hips
let's work on good bridge all right so I
want you to push your butt up squeeze
the gluts and slowly lower it down and
bring it up push it up squeeze it lower
it down and so imagine that's a string
pulling through your belly button in a
straight line good squeeze it up squeeze
and release hold for two counts at the
top up squeeze okay good
and the dumbbells will basically
increase the intensity of this workout
back down up squeeze very good you
should also feel your hamstrings back
down one more up and down okay now let's
get back up Oh doing okay yeah that's a
lot of you know like sound effects
happening right
so holding onto the waist let's go back
to the first workout squat to lunch okay
all right so let's start with a squat
first let's go squat and then left leg
back to a lunge
good so this is the second run squat and
lunge back very good
so pace yourself remember it's about
pushing your butt back keeping your
chest up squat nice and lunch whoa my
lower body my legs are on fire let me
know in the comments below if your legs
are on fire as well back down squat push
your butt back down one more nice squat
and one more lunch and very good okay
now let's work on your inner thighs and
your outer glutes place the dumbbells in
the middle all right it's that white
with the toes pointed out really making
sure you have a good foundation okay and
with in without it
take this time to breathe catch your
breath and let's go back down pushing
your butt out of cake your knees should
be pointed out do not collapse you need
inwards squeeze down up squeeze the
glutes at the top two cuts squeeze it
good feel your glutes working feel your
inner thighs pushing through your heels
very nice I am feeling gooood let's keep
going
you have ten seconds left down and up
squeeze down and up good look straight
ahead
smile and one last one down and up okay
narrow two white squat all right now
let's challenge yourself let's stay low
throughout the entire workout if you
feel that this is too much
feel free to drop the dumbbells if not
stay with me okay up just place the
dumbbells on your shoulders let's go
narrow double pulse step out
keeping a low position double house in
okay do not come up low position nice
very good
by keeping this position we are
constantly engaged engaging every single
muscles in our legs and glutes out pulse
in pulse if you have to come back up and
get back down down view more five
seconds whew
stay with me last one and okay down onto
the floor glute bridge okay all right
very good now let's work on single leg
glute bridge okay so let's place the
heels close to your butt
let's lift your left leg up let's all
right are you ready lift your left leg
up let's push up back down up back down
just small pulses up and down very good
up squeeze and down so you should feel
the work on your right glute up back
down one more up back down and switch
over right leg up squeeze now the work
should be on your left glute up squeeze
back down and back down few more you're
over there
down push it up last one more up and
down and just drop the weight okay all
right
well done okay so you have a one minute
rest
drink some water wipe your sweat catch
your breath and we want to move on to
the upper body circuit how are you doing
okay oh all right
upper body circuit again you can choose
to use the dumbbells or go without the
dundas to begin with remember to always
keep yourself hydrated use the water
okay there you go
this workout is not easy you don't have
to lift too heavy it is challenging
because you're working on your strength
endurance you are constantly moving on
from well work out to the next workout
with very little rest in the tomb okay
now let's get ready let's lift the
weights all right the first workout is
going to be a el chasquis to show the
press okay so start white start with the
dumbbells just by your ears and I want
you to squeeze bring the dumbbells
together all right
elbows together out and press the
dumbbells up so show the press chest
squeeze release it and press it up good
very good there you go remember to
engage your core squeeze your core
tighten your core and keep your back
flat squeeze good so this works on the
chest muscles as well as your shoulders
squeeze in good nice and controlled
do not just let the dumbbells drop push
it up good squeeze in one more push it
up last one come on let's go last one
push it up and drop it down okay still
working on our shoulders okay the next
workout is going to be a side and front
race all right his favor workout in fact
I think most guys paper work out so
keeping the dumbbells close your thighs
let's go fight race drop it down and now
let's go for a front race good fight
open it up spread your wings and fronts
okay bend your knees slightly
have that firm foundation up and bring
it back down so palms facing in spread
your wings
palms facing down very good again spread
maintaining a 90 degree position and
forward very good
let's go nice poop breathe out one more
out up last one come on
alright let's go forward one more and
okay let's drop the weights now okay
next let's get down onto the mat
staggered push up let's work on our
right chest to begin with okay so place
your right punch back left palms forward
I'm going to do the beginner version all
right ready on your knees on your toes
Tara's on your toes let's go down push
it up go down and push it up okay good
so this will be working on one chest at
a time
down and up good down and up very good
and on the next round we want to switch
over down and up keep going down and up
nice keep pushing few more come with in
breathe out look at the ground out and
in last few more and good okay pause
workout it's going to be a Superman
squeeze this workout is probably one of
the toughest so choose to go with that
weights or you can choose to lift really
light really light there's extra kilos
is here okay so let's lie down with your
arms and your legs spread out okay ready
all right let's lift the Tambov up
squeeze it back drive it forward do not
drop back down on the ground squeeze it
forward and squeeze
so this works on your shoulders and as
you squeeze it works on your back nice
challenge yourself squeeze and forward
really reach all the way forward relax a
muffled and squeeze good this is
probably one of the most underrated
workout but extremely effective and it's
also one of Terrence's favor workouts
oh okay drop the weights all right okay
are we get to continue yes all right
no time to waste let's grab the weights
let's move on to the second circuit you
should be sweating I am absolutely
drenched right now okay let's start with
an L squeeze to show the press good
squeeze and press it up very nice grease
press it straight up and get your car
tighten your abs press it up feel your
shoulders working you know the burning
shoulders press it up squeeze it press
it up come on guys you have ten more
seconds press it up last few more give
me at least two more last one more
squeeze and rest okay relax relax for a
little okay just drop the weights relax
okay next alpha body workout 5 & Run
race okay
so place both dumbbells close to your
thighs with your palms facing in
okay let's start with a side race ready
and go side raise up down and forward
good so working on the side dumps and
the win belt okay good keep going nice
control the dumbbells down don't just
let it drop up control it down up and
control very good squeeze it good
keeping your chest up and your back flat
and remember if you want to you can bend
your knees slightly forward back down up
good move it's heavy he is lifting heavy
last one forward oh good
very good job I know you don't do this a
lot but you do you wrong okay
to get back down onto the floor they get
push-ups so now you want to place your
right hand forward okay right hand
forward left hand back all right
so choose your option either on your
knees or your toes let's go push good
push very good so isolating the muscles
good up and down this is a more advanced
push up push it up and now don't rush
okay because it is not easy
take your time try as many reps as you
can keep going down and up down and up
good
that's few more 10 more seconds
give me three more one that's two more
- that's one more three and up all right
okay wrap the lightweights okay last
workout for your upper body so Superman
squeeze whoop absolutely drenched and
I'm feeling good okay so spread both
legs and arms out okay relax take your
time to breathe and ready let's go up
squeeze forward and squeeze if you
really have to feel free to drop the
weights lift it back up and squeeze okay
whoo I remember to squeeze your gluts at
the same time we want to work on the
entire body you should also feel the
work on your lower back forward and
squeeze forward squeeze for two counts
forward squeeze and squeeze very good
few more we're almost there
last two more last one okay all right
come back up get into a child's pose
stretch it out just relax and stretch it
out
breathe you have done really well okay
so one minute rest okay final circuit
you have completed two circuits and this
is your last circuit I am drenched in
sweat and he barely sweats and so it's
really good that to see that his
sweating and it's really helping with
his strength endurance as well all right
so keep yourself hydrated drink some
water and for the final circuit it's
great to be working on your core all
right grab some water oh thank you okay
twenty more seconds okay you can put the
dumbbells away if you want to okay are
we ready we have five more seconds let's
start with spider-man plank all right
so place your pumps on the floor start
in a high plank
spider-man plan ik drive for your left
knee close to your left elbow right knee
close to your right elbow that's it
do not Pike up stay in a plank position
good so take your time drive your left
to your left side good right - right
gaze gently on the floor
very good so working on your Bleek's
nice keep going nice and controlled okay
do not rush through the workout nice and
controlled very good last few more
that's one more on each side one on the
right and back it down okay so now let's
sit on our butt all right and again if
at all you need to get into a child's
pose feel free to do so
so now let's sit on our butt we want to
work on knee types so place your palms
on the floor with your fingers pointed
forward and we're just gonna drive our
knees close to our chest okay
ready let's go driving knee close your
chest back out and back in that's it
okay good out and in good keep going
very nice
out and in nice and controlled again
with core exercises do you not rush
through them okay it is not just about
completing the workout but it's about
feeling the muscles working feel the
shake that's good alright keep going
rough it out drop it back in drop it out
and back in and out last few more keep
going that's one more in and up all
right give me one more
okay drop it up
okay now let's lie down okay we want to
get into flutter kicks so it's about
fluttering your leg like sorry you make
love and right so place up hands close
to your butt okay alright with your legs
extended straight out
all right lift your legs up and now
let's go left and right
that's it good left and right left and
right okay whoo you will really feel on
your lower abs left and right
point your toes very good breathe in
relax I know you can realize but just
think about something else besides the
pain you're feeling when you call right
now keep going last few more 10 more
seconds you got this I can feel the burn
let's not stop right now push through
and you are done okay all right okay
all right let's go get back up let's
still lie down okay if you need to rest
feel free to wrap lift your legs up okay
in a 90-degree position and all I want
to do is to reach left to right on your
ankle okay so it's a site-to-site time
ready so reach left and right that's it
there you go
so it's working on your obliques and by
lifting your legs you will be engaging
your entire core as well so just tap
left to right left to right okay and
just gaze forward remember you're
lifting your shoulders off it's not
straining your neck good left to right
left to right very good keep going
and remember to breathe out cuckoo okay
breathe out good few more tap seven
down all right stretch out quickly okay
straight legs stretch it out a little
bit and now if you need a longer stretch
feel free to do so if not get back up
and let's move on to the second round
only four minutes left and that's the
end of your workout okay spider-man
plank so stay up right knee to right
elbow left knee to left elbow okay
keeping your back flat in a high plank
position
good keep going left and right left and
right
okay please you're breathing I can see
my sweat-drenched on the mat good then
right left and right very good
breathe okay pace your breathing very
good last one more and done all right
now let's sit on our butt haha so so
sweaty
alright ready let's work on knee tucks
okay so again palms facing forward
fingers pointer forward if you need to
you can always do a beginner version
where you rest your heels on the floor
ready so point forward drop it in rest
it tap it on the floor drop it in and
tap it okay if this is too easy then
let's keep your heels elevated
good out and in very good how Dineen
to your chest okay good push it in and
squeeze your abs as you drive your knees
into your chest release control drive it
in very good keep going less than 10
seconds keep driving it in squeeze I can
feel the burn last few more and drop it
down all right now let's just lie down
on the mat alright
the case for an easier version what you
can do is place your pants underneath
your butt okay because I want you to
avoid arching your low back so place
your pumps underneath your butt and
drive both legs up okay
point your toes and flutter left and
right left and right and just relax your
upper body okay all the work should be
on your lower abs good keep going
left and right left and right and
remember just breathe in and out pace
your breathing very good this is such a
simple yet extremely effective workout
keep going
last few more doing well last two more
and drop it done okay very good
one final workout and you are done
okay okay so again bring your heels
close to your butt and bring both legs
up in in ninety degree position I want
you to try to reach your ankles okay
left ankle right ankle ready side to
side and side to side
that's it okay good
left and right left and right very good
and remember to either look forward or
look up whichever that feels comfortable
for you you are bringing your shoulders
up okay not your neck bring your
shoulders lift your shoulders off the
mat left and right left and right last
few more last five to ten seconds but
today's workout you have reached this
far
so let's complete it last few more last
two more and okay sing this moment to
just stretch your legs bring your arms
up stretch it out and just relax
okay take this moment to just breathe in
and out for the next 30 seconds just
relax
bring a hard way back down and now I
just want to point your toes and really
stretch your body and really just
stretch it okay stretch it very good
and now let's slowly come back up okay
let's come back up to a sitting position
all right let's just do a few stretches
before we end today's workout so sit
right at the edge of your mat drive your
right leg forward okay step forward and
I'm going to drop your butt down
okay so drop your butt down and just
reach up that's it
feel your left hand strings left hip
flexor being stretched out okay very
good just reach up elongate your body
and now straighten your right leg and
just reach down so you're stretching
your right hamstring so okay only go as
low as you can
very good
okay and now let's switch side okay so
left leg forward again drive your glutes
down your hip flexors towards the floor
and lift both arms up so you should feel
your right hip flexor drive up and if
you can go deeper okay and breathe and
now straighten your left leg and just
reach down stretching on your left
hamstring
okay don't you okay alright very good
and now just sit back up and let's get
into a child's pose ball final stretch
okay spread your knees apart and just
reach as far as you can try to bring
your glutes towards your heels
and now slowly come back up okay very
very very well done very well done give
me a high five all right come on he can
even new right now how do you feel great
are you not easy for big body yes very
good
yeah body belief or big muscles is very
good for cardio yeah this is also it's a
combination that's why it's called
strength and conditioning because it
combines both strength exercises but
because you're not stopping with very
little rest in between that's when
you're working on your cardio so I would
say that do strength and conditioning
based workouts at least twice a week
okay and if you want to grab your
partner and make him work hard with you
all right
the let us know in the comments below
what you enjoy about this workout and if
you would like to see us work out more
often together okay let us know in the
comments below give us a thumbs up leave
this imagery yeah if you want to see him
more on my channel and also remember to
subscribe to my youtube channel check
out my other workout videos and also hop
on to this YouTube channel Terrence - I
asked BB Pro if you want to learn more
about bodybuilding or even strength
training exercises and we will see you
next time